I finally realize who Eddie Redmayne
reminds me of in this movie richard
harris meets Buffalo Bill from Silence
of the Lambs Richard Harris with the
high voice hurry right I knew I got both
little bear with the law but I'm
together over harvest tomorrow
that's in
Jupiter ascending so Jupiter ascending
is about a girl named Jupiter played by
Mila Kunis who is going to ascend I
guess he's a classic Tayla but nobody's
like oh I'm royalty that's awesome
it's Mila Kunis she's hanging out with
her family and the scrubbing toilets for
a living Channing Tatum comes down with
his galactic roller skates kicking ass
with his guns and doing his space
gymnastics to take out baddies and he's
like you are the reincarnated soul of
the Queen so there's a huge section of
space in the universe that belongs to
you and what I liked about this movie
were a couple things first of all I'll
say the actors in the movie did fine
Mila Kunis was completely functional I
mean she could have been played by other
people for sure same with Channing Tatum
it's not like it needed to be Channing
Tatum but I was impressed with Channing
Tatum the movie looks awesome and he's
February but this looks like a summer
movie and I'll say that about the
Wachowski they always give you a
visually good time you walk out of the
movie like yeah I gotta blew my hair
back in a few parts that doesn't make
substance for a good movie I'm just
saying it was exciting enough to lot
like the movie just falls apart because
it is undeniably a complete mess sexist
movie started out as an impressive
series of storyboards it's like alright
there's the concept then the Wachowski
started writing the script when they
should have handed it off to someone
else who actually writes good scripts
and then they would have been like okay
we have some work to do but I think I
can make this work but no they took the
project on themselves and now we have
this a watchable enough disaster that
you're not going to go out of your way
to watch again this is kind of movie if
it's on TV and I'm doing something on my
laptop or dunno some project or
something I'll have it on in the
background for ambient noise but God
knows it feels long enough to probably
be on first long as whatever project I'm
doing goes on for but in terms of a mess
oh my god this movie was not cohesive at
all it's just things happen all we need
to go here we need to go there when you
go into space when you talk to this
person we need to talk to that person
Eddie Redmayne doesn't actually become
relevant until the end of the movie
before that she's dealing with the other
siblings who have their own ideology and
I did like that concept because it's
very Greek mythology now you're like oh
these people probably are what the Greek
gods are based off of that being said it
felt like level 1 we're talking to this
person right level 2 it's a little
harder now we're talking to this person
level 3 we have to fight this person
like a damn video game talk about
pissing my time away everything that
dealt with Mila Kunis is earth family in
this movie colossal waste of time I get
her having an earth family in this movie
and you could have used certain things
that they were used for in this movie
there's a whole plot point where she's
bidding for something on eBay a needs to
go get money and then it doesn't work
out and the dudes freaking out her
brothers are good already but the thing
oh god I'm not gonna get the money I'm
like what do you owe money to the mob or
some no it doesn't matter the
family was just like this little kid in
this movie waving their arms in front of
the camera being like hey every relevant
it's like no you're not this is why
generally speaking when there's a story
about a nobody who becomes a big thing
they usually make the nobody orphan so
it's like here you're an orphan now you
don't have a family why cuz it's easier
that's why if you don't believe me watch
Jupiter ascending so in the end Jupiter
ascending looks great everyone in the
movie did their parts well enough Eddie
redmayne's character I don't get why he
had to have a weird-ass voice the
mythology was good enough the concept
was good the scope was grant I only say
that about which ASCII movies like the
scope is huge but it's never refined to
be a great movie not anymore I feel like
The Matrix was a fluke in the end you're
not gonna remember Jupiter ascending in
t-minus one day yep already forgot why
is the Jupiter ascending have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more